- So it's been a
pretty crazy day so far.
Just checking my email.
Give me one second.
So let me give you the recap.
(rap music)
("Purple Feelings ft
Rainsford" by Jerry Folk)
Let me give you the recap.
Big meeting with Viacom,
Business Insider,
and TiVo, Triple Lift,
internal team.
Big client I can't mention.
Quick little brunch.
Couple phone calls.
Men panel here now at
the female quant and...
Meeting with Jack Dorsey,
CEO of Twitter at 4:15.
Pretty productive day.
Couple other big meetings.
CMO dinner tonight.
And then out tomorrow morning.
Everyday I think people
are thinking about it from a
defensive standpoint and
everybody's got
some version of this.
Whether it's too
left or too right.
You know, I think that's so
much of what's going on in the
conversation of social media in
our societies so I don't know if
it's a blind spot or
if it's been accepted,
I don't know if
everybody accepted it as well.
I just think everybody defaults
to defense and they're finding
which one of the words they
want to come out of their mouth.
I think it's the baseline
of how people are thinking.
("Purple Feelings ft
Rainsford" by Jerry Folk)
Great job.
I thought the
history books, so cliche,
the only meeting that
I gave a shit about all week,
not really but kinda,
I'm late for because
I was stuck on the panel.
So handsome, it's crazy.
- Ah!
- Will I see you tonight?
("Purple Feelings ft
Rainsford" by Jerry Folk)
You know, no, it's
funny you said that.
As you know, I haven't really,
I mean I've done one or two wine
videos in six years
after doing them everyday.
- 1,000.
- Thousand of them
everyday for five years.
But my new infatuation with
podcasting and audio I think I'm
going to do a monthly
wine podcast on my
GaryVee audio experience where
I drink wine with
some people and we just
slurp and (mimics slurping)
it's gonna be really funny and
awkward but I'll
have interesting people.
I think it'll be really
interesting content and then
we'll see how it feels.
I may even reboot Wine Library
TV with Wine Library Audio.
We'll see.
It's funny that
you ask me that today.
If you asked me five
months ago, I would just say no.
No. I did it, it was a
nice part of my life.
I like enjoying wine.
- Yeah.
- But now, I think I see
a light to a comeback.
My French
entrepreneurs, I love you.
Keep hustling.
Just remember no government,
no company stops you.
Do your thing.
- That was great.
- My friend.
Great to see you.
- Thank you.
("Last Day" by Shallou)
Guys, Vortex 2018 is gonna be
the best conference ever.
You're just gonna enter,
you're just gonna enter it.
(laughs)
We're just gonna have
people walk into something and
we'll be like
there's nothing activated.
And they're
like, "What the fuck?"
And we're like,
"You're in the Vortex."
("Last Day" by Shallou)